euh qu'est-ce que vous racontez dans vos
chansons est-ce que le futur est mort
est-ce que c'est la société qui vous a
mis là et qui vous fait souffrir
qu'est-ce que vous avez à vendre bah
déjà que je sais pas on entend on voit
trop de merde à la télé alors
heureusement qu'on y passe quoi parce
que quand alors attendez est-ce que vous
avez à vendre et bien c'est un album je
vais le vendre attends je vous parle non
parce que sinon d'accord mais là je suis
en train de nous parler donc vous me
regardez un petit peu voilà le cri de la
mouche voilà un album voilà et puis
comme vous êtes sympa quand même j'ai
rappelé que le 25 mai vous serez au
Bataclan voilà
on joue le 25 mai au Bataclan et ça va
carrément déchirer alors venez tous
voilà je vous avais dit c'est un cri
audible partout bon attendez je vais
finir ma phrase d'accord moi je veux
bien vous fassiez de la télé mais enfin
essayer de voyez bon ça s'appelle
comment le titre qu'on va écouter
et ta mère bon d'accord
ça donc ça se trouve sur l'album
ok d'accord bah on écoute et ta mère par
le cri de la mouche qu'on applaudit bien
fort et ta mère